thanks
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
vaccines for the treatment and
prevention of cancer
presented by dr keith knudsen
i am tracy aston martin of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
biotechne for more information on our
sponsor
please visit biotechne.com now let's get
started
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr keith knudsen
a professor of immunology mayo clinic
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr knutson you
may now begin your presentation
thank you so much and thank you for the
opportunity to
speak with you all today about
our vaccine program that we've been
developing over the last
many many years now and predominantly
for
breast and ovarian cancers which is i'm
going to talk about but many of the
principles
that we've established and others have
established
can potentially work well for other
cancers as well just a
few conflicts of interest we've licensed
some of the technologies to a variety of
companies who are
are moving these therapeutics forward
so let me just remind many of you that
uh worldwide we have an extensive burden
of breast and ovarian cancers
approximately
2.2 million cases per year worldwide and
800
000 deaths so in the u.s we have
approximately 240 000 cases of breast
cancer
about 300 000 total if you add in
ductal carcinoma in situ which is a very
early form of breast cancer
and something that we haven't done much
is the mortality rate
which stands at about 40 000 deaths per
year a much rarer cancer
is ovarian cancer we only have 22 000
cases
but because ovarian cancer is
typically found in its very advanced
stages
its mortality rate is quite high with
about 14 000 deaths per year
it's a very costly disease in the u.s we
estimate that it costs
about 180 billion dollars a year to
manage all of the different aspects of
breast cancer and ovarian cancers which
is about
0.2 percent of our gross domestic
product so
we need to continue efforts to not only
reduce the mortality but
reduce the burden that breast and
ovarian cancers
put on our society so many of you
uh may have a background in immunology
some of you may not and and so i'm going
to just give a little short course on
the adaptive immune system and the just
to put it simply the adaptive immune
system is the body's drug making
machinery
and it consists of predominantly three
types of
uh adaptive immune cells the b cell the
cd4 t
cell and the cd8 t cell so we typically
think of cd4 cells as being helper cells
they coordinate the immune response
they're at high levels
peripheral blood they can sense out
antigen and they can induce a wide
variety of immune responses
including activation of cytotoxic t
cells
which are cells that
essentially lyse infected cells
or tumor cells through presentation of
antigen in the context of mhc
class 1 molecules which is shown here
cd4 t
cells activate in response to antigen
presented in
mhc typically mhc class 2 molecules
while b
cells produce antibodies which can
impact
tumors in a number of different ways and
so
there's about 10 to the 18 different
specificities
due to genetic recombination in the b
cell and t cell compartment
of proteins that can recognize
specific antigens so we have many many
vaccines about 40 vaccines that
are targeting about 28 different
diseases here in the us
and so you know literally we've only
touched the tip of the iceberg in terms
of the
immune system and how we can interrogate
and
activate the immune system against
specific diseases and that includes
cancer
now what we've known over the past many
many years and something that'll
that'll help you understand some of our
later slides is that
the in addition to the
uh different adaptive immune effectors
as well as the
antibodies or the t cell receptors that
recognize mhc
molecule there's many different flavors
of the adaptive immune system
we typically think of you know based on
earlier studies that the immune system
either polarizes into a th1
or a th2 profile and that
has been a long-standing paradigm that
has persisted in in the immunology
litter for
literature for many many years but over
the past decade
or so we have seen
many descriptions of other types of t
cells and these different
flavors of t cells are becoming
essentially associated with a variety of
different types of diseases
and some get activated in specific types
of cancers
and so as we move forward in vaccine
development
it is going to become useful information
for us to try to understand
what types of immune effectors to
activate and i'll come back
in more detail on that a little bit
later so we've known
for both breast and ovarian cancer for
many many years now since the mid-1990s
that the immune system
naturally responds to these cancers and
that the t
cell responses are associated with
improved survival
telling us that the immune system can
have activity
the question is how do we develop
therapeutic approaches to
target these cancers based on vaccine
technology this is just an example of a
study that was published
way back in in 2013 uh looking at
gene signatures associated with a couple
of different flavors of t
cells th1 which typically is like a
macrophage
associated immune response with high
levels of interferon gamma
lower levels of antibody responses and
but what we see here in her2 positive
breast cancer is that there's follicular
helper cells
also associated with improved survival
so the higher
level of signature gene signature that
you have
in tumor the better survival that you
have relative to not
having that signature so this is just an
example
of the signatures of immune responses
that we typically see
within cancers demonstrating that the
immune system
can have activity and the goal of
vaccination the goal of immune
checkpoint blockade
adaptive t-cell therapy is to harness
that incredible activity
to eliminate the tumor or even prevent
it
part of the work that we did early on
was initially
understanding what the immune system was
responding to and so
we did a number of studies early on to
demonstrate conclusively that
while immune infiltration is associated
with improved survival
these patients also have peripheral
levels of b
cells and t cells that are specific for
specific antigens that are overexpressed
in the
tumor microenvironment and so we
continue to put together information
from breast and ovarian cancers and
others do this with other cancers as
well
to try to identify what those targets
are that we can formulate into cancer
vaccines
so one way to think about it is to
divide them up into
three groups basically so we have
microbial neoantigens
we have mutation derived neoantigens
which
are very popular these days to
interrogate and formulate into
different therapeutic strategies and the
approach that we took several years ago
was to develop vaccines based on
non-mutated self-antigens
by virtue of over-expression or other
abnormal presentation
in the tumor microenvironment revealing
what we call
subdominant neoantigens
we know in breast and ovarian cancers
that there's no
microbial etiologic agents
that we can target for example in
cervical cancer head and neck cancer
or in liver cancer we see
viral elements so human papilloma virus
for
cervical cancer and hepatitis b virus
for liver cancer and we can target those
with antigens now that we have good
sequencing technology we can understand
the landscape of mutation
derived neoantigens and i'll get a
little bit into that
as time moves on but most of our efforts
have been
put forth in identifying non-mutated
subdominant neoantigens that we can
formulate into vaccine approaches
and this is put graphically
in this particular slide where
on the left side you can see a normal
cell and you have a protein for example
her2 nu
which is often over expressed in breast
cancers
gastric cancers esophageal cancers
under normal conditions it's expressed
at very low levels
and you have epitopes that derive
from the processing of those levels of
her2 expression that get presented
dominantly in mhc molecules and your
immune system is good at tolerizing its
self either through central deletion of
the t
cells or antibodies or the generation of
regulatory t cells and
i'm not going to go into all of the data
that we have to support that but
you know this is something that we have
to regularly
show for example to the food and drug
administration
that the epitopes that we have aren't
expressed
on normal cells whereas in a tumor cell
when you have aberrant expression of say
her2nu for example
again you have mislocalization in the
cell you have
different degradation you have
different glycosylations that can all
impact
the presentation of epitopes
and we see this
with a wide variety of tumor antigens
and what happens is due to this over
expression
you get processing and presentation of
what we call subdominant evidence
and your immune system is not tolerant
to those
so your immune system recognizes those
and we can interrogate those we can
identify those and formulate
in those into vaccines actually we
started this back in the mid
1990s when there was very little
understanding
of the potential role of vaccines
in treating and preventing cancer
and so with this we
targeted her to knew at the same time
that herceptin was being developed and
we came up with
several different vaccines and we've
immunized
individuals many individuals with these
vaccines
for example her2 ecd vaccine the
extracellular domain the intracellular
domain
and a couple of other different vaccines
based on class
1 epitopes most of the focus of our work
has been
on mhc class 2 or cd4 t-cell epitopes
given that we want to apply the vaccines
as a prevention agent so secondary
prevention in
individuals that have been previously
treated for
breast or ovarian cancers that had been
rendered
disease-free and most of the
vaccine studies that were done back at
that time were done
in individuals with very advanced stage
disease and so that was very problematic
because
it turns out that seeing very advanced
disease
when you have bulky malignancy on board
you have a lot of immune suppression
that prevents the development
of the immune response and prevents this
activity
in the tumor microenvironment so we
positioned ourselves very early on
as a vaccines as a strategy
to prevent disease and this is shown
here back from a study that we did long
time ago where we
systematically identified epitopes from
her2
and gave those when there was no disease
burden generated that immune response
and we could show
that we could block the development of
tumor whereas if we started immunization
after we gave a big bolus dose of tumor
cells it takes a long time for that
immune response to develop
and during that time it turns out and we
understand this more fully now
that the immune system actually develops
immune suppression so i'm not going to
go into all of the mechanisms there are
several
we can talk about that during q a
for example regulatory t cells is one
group of cells which are known to
infiltrate into
rest and ovarian cancers and block
immunity in fact we did
a lot of work back in the early 2000s
to show that patients that had high
levels
of regulatory t cells in their tumors
had
worse outcome because it blocks that
anti-tumor
in response so hence our application of
vaccines has been in
the minimal disease setting however we
now have agents that block this immune
suppression
opening up new avenues for us to combine
vaccines
with other types of strategies say for
example immune checkpoint blockade
that will enable the immune system to
have an impact
even though there's bulky malignancy and
immune suppression
in the tumor microenvironment but at
that time when we were developing
vaccines for her to do we had
very limited bioinformatic technologies
to help us
we had actually
algorithms that were based on mouse mhc
it was successful but
with the development of new biomedic
strategies were able to
over the last several years uh predict
self antigen over express self antigen
her2 new in this particular example
using advanced algorithms based on
known binding to many of the mhc
class ii molecules that are present in
the human population
and this is just an example of how we
take
predicted epitopes and we bind those
after prediction to mhc molecules and
then determine which ones have
higher affinity for those mhd molecules
and we tend to prioritize those ones
that bind to
multiple different hla
drb molecules
in order that we can construct a
degenerate epitope off-the-shelf vaccine
for use in individuals with a prior
diagnosis of breast and ovarian cancer
and then following that bioinformatic
and that binding studies then we go to
humans and we actually ask if
individuals have pre-existent immune
responses and we prioritize further
the identification of those neoantigens
with the observations
that a pre-existent immunity exists in
these individuals
and so this is just an example of a
peptide based vaccine
her2new p59 p88
422 and 885 which we constructed
this particular vaccine as a pool binds
to
95 percent of the hla dr molecules
that are present in north americans
and you can see the distribution so
three of those are extracellular and
one of those is intracellular in fact
we've take we've
advanced this particular vaccine
significantly which i'll get into
and it's been a useful tool also
to interrogate responses to a
wide variety of her2 new targeting
reagents agents like
herceptin or margituximab or other
agents which bind up her to new where we
can see
that when those patients are treated
with herceptin they develop immune
responses to these subdominant epitopes
so that gives us confidence that a t
cell repertoire exists in these
populations
that we can formulate into vaccines
so in this particular vaccine those four
epitopes
we just recently showed that
individuals immunized with the four
epitopes can
rapidly develop immune responses to
these epitopes
and in fact the vast majority of
individuals responded
uh with the generation of immune
responses nearly 100 percent
demonstrated immunity to at least one of
the epitopes or
to the processed antigen either icd
or ecd and importantly
the immune responses were
long lived in individuals and we could
measure those out to a couple of years
even with just a short vaccination
series
and so in this particular kind of
abbreviated subset
of that data that we
now have published we
show that following immunization we can
go back to those patients at
two years two and a half years for
example and we can see
that t cells specific for
the epitopes remain elevated in these
and this ideal outcome of course of a
vaccine is to
have persistent immunity that can
provide protection
we also see that in those individuals
that as a result of that t
cell immunity their her2 new antibodies
their endogenous antibodies
increased and in fact what we showed in
patients
uh with either in the adjuvant setting
or the metastatic setting
that higher levels of antibodies against
her2nu
are associated with improved outcomes so
this is telling us that we can
vaccinate patients and improve survival
following a diagnosis and in fact we've
just started
a phase two clinical trial and that's
going to be conducted in about 190
patients
that have undergone treatment
for her2 positive breast cancer
neoadjuvant
chemotherapy and neoadjuvant
prostitute based
therapy or her2 targeted therapy
that have not or that did not
demonstrate a complete
clinical response to neoadjuvant
chemotherapy had the remainder of their
tumor surgically removed and we're going
to be in a placebo controlled fashion
and blinded giving these individuals
this vaccine along with in this
particular case tdm1 which is
for those that you don't that don't know
it's a it's a
conjugated form of herceptin that
carries in a
drug to uh block tubulin activity so the
idea
is that the delivery of vaccine boosts
those immune responses that are induced
during maintenance therapy in these
individuals in the adjuvant setting
and be able to protect them from relapse
and so we'll have a readout
on this phase ii clinical trial which is
just funded by the department of defense
in about five years or so
we've done similar things with other
vaccine
antigens over the course of of these
several years
another example that we have
is that we see that
certain subsets of individuals with
breast cancer
specifically those with triple negative
breast cancer as well as ovarian
patients have very high level expression
of the folate receptor alpha this is a
protein that
is typically only expressed at very
select spots
typically away from the immune system in
the body
cancers for a variety of reasons maybe
the uptake of folate
over express and this aids in growth
of the tumors allowing them to get ample
supply of bullying
for their metabolism so
we went through a similar bioinformatics
approach and identified
five antigens uh class ii
cd4 t cell activating epitopes from the
folate receptor alpha
and a couple of years ago actually
published this
in clinical cancer research in which we
could
we demonstrated that we could safely
immunize individuals
and this looks at the vaccine period you
could see that
individuals developed immune responses
to the epitopes to the folate receptor
alpha
natural protein and when we went back to
those patients between 12 and 18 months
and follow-up we could also see
that they demonstrated immune responses
and this is even in the absence of
any type of booster so this approach is
is also safe in generating persistent
unity in individuals this has gone on
into a phase two clinical trial
where we're asking the same question
that we didn't heard two new but
in triple negative breast cancer whether
or not
we can immunize and protect individuals
from relapse so this trial is ongoing
multiple
centers around the country are
participating in this clinical trial
in which we delivered the vaccine after
treatment of patients with triple
negative breast cancer standard
conventional treatment surgery and
chemotherapy
triple negative breast cancer is a prime
choice for this vaccine because
relative to the other vaccine or the
the other cancers that it has much
higher levels
of folate receptor activity
but then during this time frame we
started to think about
the types of flavors of immune response
that were being detected in tumors
that were being associated with these
other subtypes of t
cells rather than the th1 th2 dichotomy
we see in ovarian cancer for example
that il-17
and th17t cells were associated with
improved survival this is studies
that were actually done by another group
but
it emphasized us that we needed to start
thinking of ways to develop
adjuvants for a vaccine that would
stimulate these unique subsets of
of t cells and so this shows that
patients with high levels of il-17 and
this has been reproduced by numerous
studies now
have much more improved survival in
ovarian cancer
relative to those that have lower levels
and so our thought was could we
construct
a vaccine that would specifically
stimulate
the development of a th17 vaccine
approach and if we could mimic
that in patients with ovarian cancer and
so we started a clinical trial and
what we do is we we teamed up with
uh martin cannon from the university of
arkansas
who had seen that if you block p-38 map
kinase and dendritic cells that's shown
here
you actually get a unique phenotype
of dendritic cells
that enabled generation of th17t cells
i'm not going to go into all of the data
but
we use this and we showed that
blockade of of p38 map kinase result
lower levels of il-12 and higher levels
of interferon gamma but at the same time
secreting very high level of cytokines
that are linked to the development of
th17
t-cell immunity and we see that
this approach is unique for generating
th17 so
we've developed animal models to study
this and what we see
is that these dendritic cell vaccines
that are
based on a blockade of p38 map kinase
and pulse with antigen not only activate
th1 immunity as shown here relative to
conventional
dendritic cells but specifically and
uniquely activate the development of
th17
immune effectors so this particular
vaccine
enables the development of th17
but also keeps th1 th2
and antibody immunity intact
and so we conducted a phase one clinical
trial which is actually
submitted and as under revision and
uh that was positive so we had
very interestingly we had a subset of
individuals
we're out at about uh five or six years
now after
initial diagnosis and treatment of these
individuals that haven't had relapse now
we would have expected
at this time probably on the order of
about
five to ten percent of patients without
relapse
so we have very durable protection of
patients the primary diagnosis of
ovarian cancer that had been treated
and that whether or not they progressed
or not was linked to the development of
an immune response so
all of the patients developed immune
responses
but those individuals that had higher
levels
of community and particularly interferon
immunity they all developed il-17 that
wasn't associated with
regression or no progression and they
had higher levels of antibodies
that were induced which was quite kind
of a surprise to us
against the folate receptor alpha those
that had no progression had higher
levels
immunity was persistent against all of
these epitopes that we included in this
both interferon gamma as well as il-17
positive t cells antibodies were also
persistent
well so this is telling us that in this
particular population
il-17 inducing vaccines may have
activity and it may be through the
generation of a coordinated
broader spectrum immune response that
potentially involves
not only il-17 but also interferon gamma
th1 cells
as well as antibody responses and so
we've modeled this we've developed a
similar vaccine
and relative to conventional dendritic
cells shown that
animals that have been injected with a
an aggressive form
of ovarian cancer can be protected more
so
than those that are immunized with
conventional vaccines in fact what we
think is happening
is something very unique is that
th17 is actually driving eosinophils and
macrophages
in the tumor microenvironment the
antibodies that get generated as a
result of vaccination
then bind fc receptors and through
antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxic or cellular phagocytic
mechanisms
tumors that are in the peritoneal
microenvironment are killed
and as a result of that these mice can
live for a long period of time and in
fact if we
couple this with uh anti-pd-1 for
example
we see very extended survival out well
past a year
is making it very difficult to do these
kinds of experiments
because it takes so long so this is
advancing into
a phase two clinical trial which we're
just getting up and running
right now in which we're going to
immunize patients with
autologous dendritic cell vaccines that
have been
treated with p38 map kinase inhibitor
and following their normal
course of therapy which is neoadjuvant
chemotherapy
sometimes all of them get surgery and
then followed with chemotherapy they'll
be randomized to one of two arms we
anticipate in this particular trial that
we will um vaccinate about
78 patients or excuse me enroll about 78
patients
two-thirds of those will get the vaccine
and then we'll give them boosters
to continue their uh the development of
their immune response or
augment their immune response or
maintain it over
the long period and then we'll watch
those individuals
see the whether or not we can reduce
relapse and then try to understand where
it's failing
what are the mechanisms by which the
tumor relapses there's a number of
different possibilities it could be
pd-1 pdl-1 it could be antigen loss it
could be
other types of immune suppressive
mechanisms
but this is telling us that if we think
about
what types of of unity
are activated in the tumor micro
environment naturally and
what are associated with improved
outcomes that we can build our vaccines
based on that knowledge
to enhance survival in individuals
previously diagnosed with cancer
now another way that people are thinking
about using vaccine including us
are to combined with immune checkpoint
blockade
and what's of interest here is
developing neoantigen based vaccines
something that we're starting to work on
and starting to do
clinical trials as well so this is a
results of a study that were published
now
a few years back in which we had a
neoantigen vaccine
and i used that term kind of loosely it
was
antigens derived from mutations as well
as
subdominant epitopes that we had
identified in fact this was three
epitopes
that we had had identified c three l
three and one from her2
legit leisumane and benicatenin and as
you can see the vaccine
when given alone can for a very short
period of time just a week
can begin to induce regression but then
the two
tumors rapidly grow out as you hear
now one of what was of interest to us at
that time was whether or not the
combination of vaccine plus
anti-pd1 could result in
in sustained anti-tumor immune responses
and eradicate the tumor completely
and in fact we found that to be the case
when we delivered
simultaneously anti-pd1
every several days with three injections
of
vaccine over the course of a week
and what we observed is that we had a
marked synergistic interaction between
vaccine and anti-pd1 and in fact
75 percent complete regression in this
particular breast cancer model
those tumors that grew out we continue
to analyze them
are highly immune edited so they figured
out ways to
lose the antigen expression despite the
fact that we had
three antigenic targets within the
vaccine
but nonetheless this is showing us that
we can significantly improve survival
of those individual mice that were
treated with anti-pd1
by the inclusion of vaccine and so this
has been
there's a couple of papers an
intervention that people have
been thinking about in terms of
improving the efficacy
of intracellular or excuse me um
immune checkpoint blockade which is
effective in some individuals but in the
vast majority
not really that effective and so
like others we have started to develop
personalized vaccines so we can
you know choose to develop vaccines
based on overexpressed antigens
but now with the development of
rapid high throughput bioinformatics
pipelines
that enables us to interrogate a
patient's
tumor dna and come up with a battery
of neoantigens that we can formulate
into vaccines and give along with immune
checkpoint blockade
and in fact this is work with uh my
partner
yan hossman who's in bioinformatics here
at mayo clinic in in florida where she
developed
a neo antigen discovery pipeline
using all the latest technologies
that were available and some that she
created and in fact
this one is a little superior to other
uh
bioinformatic discovery uh pipelines
that have been developed for neo
antigens in that
it maximizes discovery of insertional
deletion or
or indel neo antigens also includes
the um the identification of those that
result
both from uh insertions and deletions
but also
frame shifts that are induced by
fusion proteins as well and it minimizes
cross reactivity and that goes back and
it scans
all of the aberrant transcripts against
known proteins that are present in other
parts of the body so we can eliminate
new neoantigens that arise in the tumor
that may have cross reactivity
but importantly it also has optimized
hla
genotyping involved and this has been a
big
problem with these informatics pipelines
is that the identification of the
relevant hla molecules is
deficient with some of the bioinformatic
pipelines that are out there
but we've managed to solve that by
tweaking
several of the pipelines in order to
give us the
best identification of class 1 and class
2 molecules
we still are trying to figure out how to
prioritize those
and we think of breast cancer and
ovarian cancer typically
because of what's written in the
literature as
being those types of tumors which
have low levels of of neoantigens
but in fact that turns out not to be the
case if you
look at neoantigens that
come from fusion proteins or come from
small insertions deletions that result
in frame shifts
in fact if you just look at single
nucleotide variants
this looks at 835 tcga breast cancer
patients
at class 1 and class 2 you can see that
relatively
low level of neoantigens from this whole
group
but if you if you add on those
frameshift
neoantigens that are arise either from
insertions deletions or fusion proteins
you can see that's where the vast
majority of activity is
and in fact it turns out that patients
typically have a low level
of neoantigens derived as a result of
single
nucleotide substitutions whereas they
have very high levels
relative to those that result from
fusions or insertions and
deletions on the order of greater than a
thousand
uh per tumor whereas with the single
nucleotide variance it's only
uh perhaps 10 to maybe a couple a couple
of hundred
so we also wanted to examine during
the development of this pipeline whether
or not the neo-antigens are private or
public
so are there shared neoantigens that we
could potentially target
and hit subgroups and we weren't
surprised when we did this analysis
that the vast majority of neoantigens we
had nearly 500 000 that we detected from
the whole
cohort of 835 tcga patients
the vast majority of those about 440 000
were only detected in a single
individual
so this is telling us that the vast
majority of these
are private rather than public but that
doesn't mean that there's not a few
shared ones
so if we look um at uh some other
you know close at some other uh
transcripts that were present in these
tumors we do find
uh some shared new epitopes
so for example there's two one from
this protein dix dc1 and pi3 kinase
frameshift anigen from from dc1
and single nucleotide variants from pi3
kinase
there was 18 neo epitopes mostly
class 2 of neo-epitopes that we could
see
in greater than 42 percent of patients
so greater than 5
cohort but this is probably
too low to formulate into a vaccine we
didn't see anything
uh better than this but what this is
telling us is that we need to craft ways
to prioritize those neoantigens that are
private
and put those into humans
and test whether or not we can elicit
durable
immune responses so interestingly and no
interestingly enough when we when we
looked across the different subtypes of
breast cancer
as well as the different tumor stages
we see very little differences in the
amount of neoantigens so
it you know was initially thought that
you know triple negative breast cancer
for example the basal
type of breast cancer would have more
but that turns out not to be the case
in fact the only significant differences
that we saw were with luminal a
which is er er positive breast cancer
had significantly lower neoantigens than
the rest of the subtypes
and if we looked across stage it didn't
really matter those neoantigens were
present right from the beginning
and so this is a potentially useful tool
not only for advanced stage
cancer patients but also for
individuals with early stage cancer as
well
but most importantly what we found
particularly with the single nucleotide
variants in the indels
is that lower neoantigen
load correlates with worse overall
survival in these patients
whether we looked at class 1 epitopes or
class 2 epitopes
we could see that their risk
of recurrence was higher if they had low
levels now that could mean a couple of
different things
uh either that they didn't have enough
neo epitopes to stimulate an immune
response
or the immune response immunoadded in
these tumors and got rid of all the
neo-epitomes
i favor the first hypothesis
uh the most in that it turns
the neo-antigens could potentially be
immunogenic in and above themselves
without any intervention
but that may be targets for neoantigen
based vaccines
so in fact we teamed up with transgene
recently and we're starting to develop
our own strategies to test
whether or not we could generate
immunity to
neoantigens this is a phase one clinical
trial
that we just started in ovarian cancer
patients
that are going to be given first line
therapy platinum based
chemotherapy followed by surgery and of
course it's wait and see with those
particular patients and during that
wait-and-see patient
per period we're going to select
neo-epitopes
based on priority prioritization schemes
that we can formulate into a vaccine and
at the time of asymptomatic relapse
elevated ca 125 so we can start to
immunize those individuals to
demonstrate safety
with the hope that we ultimately could
go into
the combination with anti pd1
in this patient in these patients so
just
lastly now what i want to talk about is
our efforts
working with the national breast cancer
coalition and even more recently with
the national cancer institute division
of cancer prevention
to come up with a prevention vaccine for
breast cancer
it's a topic that we've been working on
for
many many years driven by this large
advocacy organization the national
breast cancer coalition
in which the concept is to to devise and
implement into the clinic into
mainstream health care
a prevention vaccine so of course i
already told you
that we can't do that with a vaccine
based on viruses or bacteria because
there's no evidence that there's
any you know causative agent that we can
target that's
foreign nor is are there any you know
neo antigens that are shared across the
board that we could formulate into a
vaccine so
we're taking this approach by evaluating
the development of immunity whether or
not it can prevent breast cancer
and it's still in its early stages by
targeting
several known overexpressed breast
cancer antigens like her2nu which i was
just talking about
and this is particularly promising in
light of the fact that the normal
uh breast is a gland a gland just like
any other gland that is exposed to the
outside
develops its own mucosal immune system
this is just an example of normal
lobules that from normal healthy
individuals stained with
h e a pan leukocyte marker cd45 or cd8
cytotoxic t
cells or dendritic cells and you can
clearly see
and we see this across the board in in
most individuals
that they have they have a an immune
response
or an immune system already associated
with the gland so our question
that we're going to be asking over the
next couple of years is whether or not
we
can specifically intervene and
get immune factors specific for tumor
antigens trafficking
into normal healthy
breast cancer so while this is being
patented we the antigens are embargoed
the national cancer institute is working
with us on developing the vaccine
it's going to be based on on both a
plasmid base
and a modified vaccinia virus anchor
based boost in individuals
lessons learned from infectious disease
vaccines
these are all prepared and we expect
that over the next
six to eight months that we will have
manufacturing done
and that we will be able to implement in
individuals
a clinical trial in which we test these
and so we've met with the fda
and they have advised us to go into
disease free individuals with metastatic
disease or
in stage 3 patients that have no
evidence of disease
and immunize first to determine whether
or not it's safe
and we can at that time interrogate
interrogate
normal breast tissue to ask questions
about whether or not
we get infiltration or surveillance with
the vaccine
induced t cells and b cell
so let me just conclude
that vaccines are probably
best used when used alone not for bulky
malignancy
so many many years ago there was a
number of vaccine trials that
kind of gave a name a bad name to
vaccines because they were ineffective
with bulky malignancy but we know
that's because the immune system is
blocked
in the tumor microenvironment by a
number of different
mechanisms so
we have you know the possibility of
intervening
in the disease-free period to boost that
immunity
and so this is where we need to do
clinical trials now these are pretty
hard to do
because this isn't something that you
immunize and can see the shrinkage of
tumor you have to actually wait for
these individuals to relapse so these
are particularly challenging
clinical trials that take you know a lot
of persistence
and effort in immunizing these patients
and continuing to follow those but we
have
several clinical trials now in which
we're doing that
we also know now that with
with advanced bioinformatics that we can
take advantage
and perhaps make more personalized
vaccines the challenges there of course
are that we need to come up with systems
in which we can rapidly
encode those neoantigens and deliver
those so
a number of companies as well as our
laboratory are working on
very rapid production strategies for
making uh
neoantigen based vaccines that
based on information that we get from
the
dna and rna sequencing and the
bioinformatics
and we also know that that now that we
can repolarize immune responses and
take advice from what the body's natural
immune system is already
doing to prevent redevelopment of the
tumors and skew the immune responses to
those unique flavors that we see
you can do that with ondola against
disease like we've shown
but certainly there's going to be
improved adjuvants that can help us skew
the immune responses
as well and we need to you know also be
thinking about
you know are neoantigen based vaccines
going to be useful in treating patients
that don't have any response to
monotherapy mono icb therapy
and then ultimately there is growing
enthusiasm
based on the safety profile and based on
animal models that we can actually
prevent the development of cancers in
the first place and
and there's a couple of different
cancers that people are are trying to do
that
uh with and we're trying to lead the way
with developing the first prevention
vaccine for breast cancer
association with the national cancer
institute
and the national breast cancer coalition
so i'll end it there and i thank you
very much
for your attention you know of course
there's just many many people that have
been involved in these these are huge
efforts by clinicians by scientists
by advocacy organizations
uh granting uh foundations and and
organizations that provide monetary
support
to uh get these uh uh programs
up and going and the hope is someday
that we'll
learn better how to use vaccines to
prevent disease and there's been a
number of different clinical trials that
have been published in the past
few years that show the possibility of
or the right clinical setting of four
vaccines in
preventing or potentially even cancer
and with that i will stop and
take any questions that you may have
thank you dr knutson for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started we have a lot of
questions coming in
our first question is can we produce
cancer vaccine from secondary
metabolites produced by
microbes well the
so um i guess the
so there's a couple ways to think about
that we certainly so one of the
the um you know issues as i had alluded
to with vaccines
is that we need to um you know come up
with
better ways to skew the immune response
and so if
i it could be that this particular
question is referring to
metabolites that skew the immune system
and so we could possibly we're working
on
some of those so for example we're
working
on the development of
novel lipids from some microbes like
pgenjavalis
that will enable the activation of the
immune response
in association with vaccine antigens and
so
we could use those metabolites to
activate the immune response and
you know send it down one flavor versus
another
so to speak
do you know of anywhere or anyone that
is doing
vaccine development for metastatic colon
cancer
yeah so the the place to check on so
there are
um there are vaccines that have that
are um or have been developed in the
past
and the best you know a way that
you can check is to go to
clinicaltrials.gov
and you know type in colon cancer and
vaccines
you know the problem with you know
metastatic disease of course
is that it's very heterogeneous and the
idea with vaccines would be to get in as
early as possible
during the you know development of the
tumor but um certainly there are some
some viral based approaches that i've
seen out there
and perhaps these will work in
combination with like immune checkpoint
blockade
or something like that but you should be
able to find
ongoing trials with those on
clinicaltrials.gov
by typing in keywords that could help
you find those
thank you why did you target
neo antigens to mhc class 2
hladr instead of mhc
class 1 to activate tc
so our idea um
at that time and and it still continues
to be very promising
is that we can activate um uh
cd4 t cells and they can orchestrate the
immune response
and so um and
also in vaccinating uh during
the you know period where there's no
evidence of disease
vast majority of cells in our cd4 t
cells
and they're very important in immune
surveillance and so
the idea is under the right conditions
they can respond to antigen
that is you know draining into the lymph
node and activate the immune response
and in fact we find that to be the case
in
in um in patients with ovarian cancer
with the th17 vaccine
uh that i was telling you is that uh we
see evidence of
you know vaccine-induced immune
responses but in those individuals that
relapse we also see
um evidence that their immune response
is activated
during the course of development so it's
a matter of of
immune surveillance and the fact that
the cd4 t cells are central coordinators
of the immune response
and they could potentially activate
cytotoxic t cells
uh if they sense the antigen
so that is the primary reason that we
did that and
you know also at that time we had done
several studies in older individuals
with ovarian cancer
and it turns out that older people have
you know in some cases
not all cases but a defective cda t cell
compartment
that is enriched in memory cells
responsive to viruses
and so it tends to be less of
a it tends to respond at least in some
of the older patients that we did
cd8 or class 1 targeting vaccines don't
respond that well
and they don't generate strong
memory immunity as a result of the lack
of response
whereas that's not the case with the
class 2 vaccines
like other vaccines would cancer
vaccines prevent healthy people from
developing cancers
so we we need to test that so uh
we this year we are uh
you know going to test this uh
self-antigen
vaccine um that targets multiple
breast cancer antigens in fact the idea
is to target
antigens across the board of breast
cancers and to prevent that
so this is just a brand new area and in
fact
i've been working on it for years and
it's something that hasn't been
that well embraced but i think with
the um you know the data that we have
now that you can generate immune
responses to self-antigens
and the immune response can know what to
do with those
immune responses that we can now go into
healthy individuals in their
the nci prevent program
or division of cancer prevention at the
national
cancer institute is you know looking
into
funding these types of strategies in
fact
we just received word of funding for the
breast cancer primary prevention vaccine
which we hope to get into
normal healthy individuals at high risk
for developing breast cancer
but are otherwise healthy and have not
had cancer in the past
uh thank you dr knutson okay we have
time for one more question today
and our final question is in reference
to the immune editing
is this on the tumor cells immune cells
or an
alteration or alterations in both
so that that's a very good question so
there is a wide variety of
different types of immune editing so
and it just all depends on either the
model or
the um the uh
um if you're in the human clinical
setting
and so we see loss of antigen in some of
our models
where we immunoselect for tumors that
don't have the antigen anymore
in the case of our th17 vaccine
we see that all of the individuals that
relapse
have upregulated on their cell surface
a molecule called pd l1
indicating that they're modulating the
immune system by blocking it
we also have in in ovarian cancer
seen that tumors can cause upregulation
of immune regulatory molecules and
suppress
those immune regulatory excuse me
upregulate immune regulatory molecules
and suppress the cells on which they're
expressed
and so um it just it's it's variable but
i think the important thing here is that
there are so many mechanisms by which
the immune system is regulated it has to
be otherwise it would kill you
that the tumors can take advantage of
and so
close monitoring of the immune responses
as well as the tumor
following immune based therapies i think
is going to be essential for
trying to identify the best use of it
and how to
you know prevent a lack of response so
to speak
thank you again uh dr knutson do you
have any final comments for our audience
well thank you uh for your attention
this is a very exciting time for
vm-based approaches we back in the 1990s
when we started working
when i was just a young postdoc you know
i remember that we
were kind of outcasts you know because
there was no focus on that and a lot of
people didn't feel that it
you know really would work at all
because the immune system is for
microbes viruses and bacteria and
not for tumors um but you know
persistence in following the data i
think is
is really what paid off here and
uh we're still in the infancy we're
using kind of crude
immune regulatory procedures for
altering the immune system like anti-pd1
but i think we're learning more and more
and we'll be able to make
targeted approaches in 10 to 20 years
by continuing to adapt to the knowledge
that we gain
from ongoing studies in tumor
and infectious disease immunobiology
thank you before we go yeah before we go
i'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
we had a lot of questions today and
questions that we did not have time for
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
we would like to thank you dr conninson
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor biotechnique for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye everyone